our three german air force fighter jets
have flown to romania to support nato's
mission there that follows several other
troop deployments american and british
warplanes also there to reinforce the
nato alliance in eastern europe
dominican is live for us now in berlin
with more on this so dominic is this
essentially a uh sending a message to
putin that uh we're ready for whatever
happens
yeah you need to see this as the the
sort of gesture that the germans can do
straight away
as it were to bolster the romanian
air force and to send a message that
okay we're with you we understand the
concerns you have given what's unfolding
on your doorstep as it were in ukraine
it's clear that these three euro
fighters will not be used in any way in
ukraine they're there to provide some
reassurance although it is only three
euro fighters it's not three squadrons
of euro fighters
also it's worth noting that the
german navy is sending one small vessel
a corvette to the baltic sea to
be a visible sign of their presence to
the baltic states remember they are on
the eastern flank the baltic states of
nato you might say on the western flank
of russia and so this is as i say we
need to perceive these gestures by the
german government as reassurance and
solidarity for member states who have
borders either with russia or with
belarus germany saying yes we are there
with you and this is what we can do
straight away
and uh
uh what else have we have we been
hearing uh on this uh to tell us about
uh what else we've been hearing on this
uh dominic
well one of the other things to bear in
mind uh hasn't is that
it's not just this idea of bolstering of
sending small contingents of
of aircraft or indeed dispatching a
small or a small vessel to the baltic
sea there's also the other
prong as it were to the german approach
and that's the sanctions suggestion the
agenda of sanctions the idea of the
unilateral and the multilateral the
unilateral effect that uh the german
government brought in was a couple of
days ago when they said right
nordstrom 2 is not going to get
certified until further notice but then
there's the multilateral side of things
too we know the european union was
discussing yesterday in brussels what
form sanctions would take and we know
also that the u.s government and the uk
government were very keen to see russia
denied access or cut off
from the swift payment network the
worldwide
money transfer system as it were between
banks the german government and to a
certain extent the italian government
and french governments were resistant to
that germany's saying that actually that
could have a crippling effect on many
german businesses that have trading
links with russia and they also have
said that they would like to see the
swiss government come in alongside the
eu the u.s the uk japan in imposing
sanctions so as i say we need to view
these as a twin track approach as it
were that the german government is is
doing right now on the one hand reassure
nato member states on the eastern flank
and on the other talking about the kinds
of sanctions they can they can really
impose but they are facing questions
about this swift access with the
serious conservative politicians who are
not in government anymore anymore saying
why can't we do it
dominic cain life for us in berlin
thanks dominic